in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Matt
and Kayla are with us hey guys how are
you great welcome welcome where do you
live we live in bedford texas bedford
now what's that in here it's right in
between Dallas and Fort Worth okay cool
well good to have you guys welcome to
Nashville and you're here to do your
debt-free scream we are I love it how
much have you paid off ninety-two
thousand way to go and how long did that
take I took three and a half years about
40 months very good and your arrange of
income during that time so we started at
98 and ended up about 150 oh right cool
what do y'all do for a living I'm a
recruiter huh and I'm a mechanical
engineer very good session alert good
for you guys very cool so what kind of
debt was the ninety two thousand dollars
it was mostly my student loan debt okay
what would a bank my car got it so long
have you two been married since 2012
I'm guessing that's how this whole thing
got started did you got married and said
Kayla goes okay Matt you're cool you can
stay but the student loans got to go so
actually I I will say that I did as soon
as I graduated from college I realized
hey I've got a lot to deal with here and
my mom actually gave me the Total Money
Makeover and I read it and I thought now
I'll just pay this off quick I always
thought it'll be fast but after learning
how much it costs to live you know even
on a good salary you don't realize it
can take a long time yep so yeah and
then along comes Kayla and you get
serious that's right about about her and
about evicting Sallie Mae that's right
marrying Matt I would also be marrying
Sallie Mae that's right the kick is old
ugly aunt out of the spare bedroom there
we go I love it fun well good for you
guys so you get hitched and as you're as
you're dating tell me how this comes up
people always ask me when do you Dave
when do you tell people you have ninety
two thousand dollars in debt and I'm
going crap I don't know
so y'all tell us so when Kayla when did
he tell you how many dates in before you
found out this guy was saddled with this
oh man it was several I think we've
gotten serious and we'd started talking
about marriage
ready and he said I think there are some
things you need to know before we you
know get really really serious oh no
that was very honest he was transparent
good presented in a great way because as
an engineer he loves to research and he
had a great plan and so I thought okay
I'm signing up for this I'm good with
that
okay so his plan he says okay I've got
this but we're getting rid of it that
was the plan yes okay good sale mat good
good that fire right so how long have
y'all been dating before this comes up
how many months I think it was about
eight or nine Wow I wrestled the whole
time with when do I tell her this
because it's like a big question yeah
you got me because you don't just tell
any whole person you know but it's got
to be starting to get and I guess the
bigger the debt the more seriously
relationships got that's where you
reveal it that's right yeah Oh fun you
guys are great thank you so what do you
tell people you got a young couple out
there dating right now
and they've had the define the financial
relationship discussion and they still
call it that my kids called it that back
in high school yeah I don't know if they
still called the DTR I know that term
yeah that I just put financial in there
I just added that I'm being creative
right here and all that but anyway so
once you've had that you guys sit down
and you get an attack mode what do you
tell people the key is if they're out
there listening in there they're getting
serious they're thinking they're going
to get engaged and they're facing this
how did you do this in three-and-a-half
years what are the keys for them to do
well I'll come clean and say that I when
I first presented the you know the whole
get debt-free plan was I didn't do it
well and it wasn't my heart but the way
that it came out was this is what we're
gonna do and and let's let's by the way
we should sell your car because that's
gonna I made that mistake and so I would
say you're already so so that was
actually after
you way to drop that bomb die for the
honeymoon things not to do we're
covering now so I would say the reason
I'm coming clean is so done for any of
the guys out there that are doing this
don't do it that way come at it from
love and say I care about our future and
you and I think the key for us was
taking financial peace through church
we've been married and we'd been having
some of these big budget discussions and
you know matt was already gizelle
intense he was ready for rice and beans
no AC and I'm selling your car oh yeah
yeah and I wasn't quite there yet and so
I think financial piece really helped us
get aligned I mean even you know
something that I'll admit was I it took
some time for me to get used to seeing
our debt instead of your dead and so
that was something that was big for us
to become a team and get on the same
page but it was really fun once we got
to that point instead of the budget
being the b-word bad word it became good
and you know I'm really competitive and
so that started to make it more fun and
I thought okay how low can we get this
grocery bill this month yes it becomes a
game it's gamification yeah yes monopoly
we're gonna kick its butt yeah that's
very cool very cool so what happened
Kayla that's that's very that's cool I
appreciate you being that authentic um
what happened in Financial Peace
University that that caused you to shift
on some of those things you did you did
it was it was it recognizable to you or
was it subtle something that happened
during the class was it somebody talking
during the small groups or something
happened to him one of the videos you
went how all sudden that switch flipped
in you you know I'm talking about I do I
think it was more of a subtle shift I
think you know we realized it's God's
money anyway in order to be good
stewards with that and so we remembering
just that higher calling was big for us
and I think just the plan is simple and
whenever I saw the big number and I saw
the interest it seemed very daunting and
I think that's why I was I was not
gizelle intense because it felt like it
was going to take forever but
yes but then once we you know put pen
and paper to it and built out our
spreadsheet I became more on board and
thought this is doable we can knock this
out you guys are sharp you are sharp
you're so Raph you're so yeah well I can
imagine yeah yeah on that paper with a
little squares yeah I know the paper
yeah they engineered by oh my gosh you
guys are your authenticity is refreshing
thank you thanks for being real when we
we also wanted to share that Murphy was
a big part of it I learned and then we
would say that encouraged to try to
encourage people we we did what we did
but I had a knee surgery at a shoulder
surgery all the rehab that goes oh
really
and then car my car died so I didn't you
know save a just stop with the put the
dead for the disco ball hold you know
and so you can do it even despite
setbacks you can do it yeah way to go
you guys well we've got a copy of Chris
Hogan's book retire inspired for you
because that's the next chapter become
very wealthy and outrageously generous
and that's your next step you guys are
heroes I'm very very proud of you well
done you're living your life well and
you're living it together beautifully
it's need to talk need to talk to you
ninety-two thousand dollars paid off at
three and a half years making ninety
eight to 105 Matt and Kayla Dallas Texas
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three
well Don you two very well done and that
is just awesomeness right there this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show